hey it's Evan Carmichael I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and
today i'm answering a question from one
of my readers amber who wrote in from my
newsletter she has a business called
with pure heart just open the first
location congrats on that ember as a
website one of my feedback to bit rough
I built it with WordPress myself so
let's see what we can do to give amber
some help so this is the website with
pure heart inc a transformational
journey to fitness not bad it's
interesting that makes me a little
curious you don't want to just be a
regular fitness company I want to know
what makes you different so I'm curious
to learn more about how your services
are a little bit different let's see in
general what the websites all about is a
wordpress template that's okay it's
great if you you know don't have any
technical skills gives you the ability
to update your website really easily and
have a professional design I'm not quite
sure what this is all about I guess it's
a you know relaxing or part of the
transformational journey it'd be great
to see if you had a logo or something in
there you can go to a website like
99designs and and get a logo done for
you professionally and without spending
a lot of money this is the websites we
have a picture we have a welcome message
I would add more content here so before
even looking at the messaging I'd had
more text if you want to rank in Google
you want to have more text on the page
and look at least 500 words I'd have a
better layout right now it's it's what
for big chunky paragraphs especially
this one makes it hard to read there's
no sub headlines there's no bullet point
so you're really asking the reader to do
a lot of work here so you want to make
it easier let's read the message in a
little bit so you will find that with
pure heart we strive to help you reach
your very best with this increased
energy cardiovascular endurance core
training flexibility treatment for pain
management blah blah blah we believe
octave body okay so you're talking a
little a lot about I guess some of the
things that you're doing but I'm not
quite sure what you actually do like are
you a training company are you a
nutritional company what are your
services you want to make that really
clear so at the top of transformational
journey into fitness
a so I'm assume is fitness related but
I'm not actually sure what it is that
you do so you talk about lymph fluid
being moved through the body as a way of
muscle contraction it's confusing and
right now I don't care like I'm
wondering what does your company do
let's see if you have it later on so
here we talk about a phone number
personal training massage therapy
packages corporate chair massage and
fitness okay so this is this is better I
want to know that earlier and take out
some of this information that is too
dense and is not value-add yet so lymph
drainage is important in the diagnosis
diagnosis prognosis and treatment of
cancer you're kind of jumping all over
the place with this paragraph here so
you want to tighten that up keep it
really focused and explain what you do
and why I should care and what's the
journey like I like this start here
transformational journey to fitness
what's my transformational journey I
don't I don't see any of that in here so
you want to definitely explain that I'm
sure you have a good answer it's just
not coming across on your page finally
it's great to see a picture i love when
entrence for pictures of themselves
obviously you're very fit it's a great
looking picture I can't see your face
and so that makes me care little less
you'll find that when you can see a
close-up of somebody's face it draws
them in a little bit more makes him feel
closer to you they like you trust you I
feel like they know you a little bit
more so it's okay to have one of your
body it's a great picture maybe you'd
have a second one it shows your face or
make this picture bigger so we can see
your smiling face as well let's dig
deeper and give some tips on the inside
so I'll click on our services and see
what it is that you do so our services
okay so we have a big picture of a
waterfall and then it's blank okay okay
so a little happy face here I guess
you're still working on it so we need to
make this better put some content up
here somebody clicks on your services
they need to know what it is that you do
let's maybe click on self-defense
training as a service and see what kind
of content is up okay so this looks
really new so you got to add some
content here for each one I be looking
at 500 words plus of content to explain
what it is
what is it you do how you're different
and have a call to action I'd also look
at modifying your WordPress to put your
keywords here up in URL that'll help
with your SEO so this should be
self-defense training so they'll help
you a little bit but you definitely want
to build up your content let's dig
deeper a little bit our team let's click
on Christina Butler Christina Butler is
another picture now this isn't you so
I'm a little confused why I don't see
amber on here I'm seeing Kristina Butler
but ok you would definitely one have
your own information here and again the
picture is too far away I want to see
Christina's face I don't care that she's
by a waterfall I want to see her smiling
face looks like she has a great smile
it'll help draw me in a little bit more
she's a registered dietician and
licensed in North Carolina so I'm a
little confused again here because again
I'm not seeing amber but also I thought
we were talking about fitness and now
we're talking about a dietitian and I
don't see what she does it's related to
fitness so if that's a holistic thing
that you're doing its diet and fitness
then you want to definitely incorporate
that and explain it to me as somebody
who's coming to your website because
here it's only talking about fitness not
about the dietitian and your your
homepage talked about massage therapy
chair massage therapy and and fitness
program so now I'm confused as the wise
as a dietitian the only information on
your our team page is that now maybe
you're still you know building it up
that's okay but you definitely want to
make that a little clearer so that i can
understand what is it you do let's look
at the testimonials it's a great page
okay so blank again you def you want to
have testimonials up on here it adds a
lot of social proof again we want to put
our keywords up in here and if you have
any really key great testimonials it
also put one or two on my homepage and
ideally have a picture of the person who
is saying the testimony as well again
just to draw people in and not just have
it buried on a testimony on this page
that people may never actually look at
and then let's look at newsletters one
last thing let's click on one of your
newsletters
and so newsletter why exercise and eat
healthy okay great topic here's our
newsletter so okay i love that you
bolded a few things that's great but
this is messy this is this is hard to
read i'm not going to read this
humongous long paragraph you need to
break that up more i'd left align it i
would put some subtitles in here to make
it easier to read if you have some point
form make that easier to read as well
and it has to be longer 500 words plus
if you want to get it ranked and start
driving traffic to to these pages so
those are my initial thoughts hopefully
that helps good luck and building up
this website and let me know as you
continue your transformational journey
into building an amazing website for
those of you who are watching this video
if you liked it please give it a thumbs
up and i will do more for you and I want
to hear what you have to think to let me
know what you think about this video and
if you have a question for your own
business I'd love to hear from you just
leave it in the comments section below
and I'll do a video reply for you thank
you guys so much and I will see you soon